[Music]
when something's organic and real yeah
an audience recognizes it and they love
it they love mistakes they love when
things go off the rails
I remember watching a show once and I
was sitting there with my whole family
and it was a sketch that you were in and
there's a horse right behind you you
could tell that what happened was not
supposed to happen
and it was fantastic television well I
was singing we were doing a take off on
a Mickey Rooney Judy Garland movie so
I'm singing this song and and we live on
a farm right now and so while I'm
singing this song like Judy Garland you
know and it's kind of a funny song and
so behind me was a horse you know just
because it was we were on a farm right
well I heard the audience start to
giggle a little more than I thought that
they would you know with the shop yeah I
turned around the horse was well you
know yes yes yeah I remember the horse
was full on relieving itself Mobley and
the horse it apparently had a huge lunch
I want to go into detail but this horse
had not gone to the bathroom in four
years started I could tell ya I started
laughing so hard and finally you know we
had to stop for a minute like that
because the the trainer came out with a
bucket too late yeah another bucket so
finally you know the the orchestra
stopped and I turned to the orchestra
leader Pete Matz and I said you want to
take it from number one or number two
but you could tell there was this great
sense of discovery and in all the
sketches you all knew your lines but
you're also willing to let if it starts
to go left and it's funny
let's all go laughs you got it which is
the real beauty of it and I never on
purpose laughed we tried to always
control it but there were times when we
did Conway went way out of his way to
try and make Harvey Korman laugh yes
that's a it was his goal in life to
destroy poor Harvey yeah you know and he
would destroy me too idea I used to say
I was so sorry I didn't invest in
depends
[Laughter]